what's the deal with airplane peanuts
okay would you rather everywhere you go
you have to run to get there i'm out on
that
i don't even care what the next one is
my back can't take it
it's literally like you go to the next
room in your house to sit like a
five-year-old
exactly always running never stretching
just always running
you always have to you have to run
somebody if someone knocks on your front
door you
have to run there you have to run
all right isis let's get those [ __ ]
infidels
or every time you speak you're shouting
so you're basically a toddler like
you're just you're so
volume shout out like right well it hurt
my voice to do worse yes
a little bit of course neither of these
are going to be fine but you have to go
like the phony
hello yeah like that you always
you say everything in that range yeah
and you're standing
i found a loophole i find a loophole
i would just ignore people oh so then i
wouldn't have to talk to them and then
when they i just wait till they say my
name 10 times and i'd be like
what so it made sense it's the loophole
because you need you need your health
you need your health
my body would just hurt so much if i did
that your sweet wife who you love
be like bill you gotta go yeah and then
she's like do you think you can
take your daughter to the park you're
like yeah and then your sweet daughter
but i could explain to her i have an
affliction
ignore the tone of my voice i love you
more than life itself
you're my best friend
so i'd love to go to the movies but
you're gonna have to do the purchase
he can't whisper during the movie yeah
he can he can shout it
he's one of my favorite actors yeah
definitely
he could do it i think the wife did it
he gives him a pop card yeah but i
actually because that would be fun
once my wife was into it i would just be
totally quiet
and you're having sex you like that
you feel so good
it would wear on her i think the
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no
but if you run everywhere you'd be in
great shape there you go
and you can maintain your your human
relationships yeah you wouldn't yell at
it but it's as simple as like you have
to go past in the middle of the night
no but i would be miserable i would
start yelling at people because your
body can't take that
yeah that'd be a lot yeah but you get
used to it what do you mean hey didn't
you have a clip
from a bill's show oh is this here i
don't know our producer sends us
folders of [ __ ] i don't know this is it
what is this
black guys who love the [ __ ] [ __ ]
good
if you're a hot black guy and you want
to [ __ ] me at 23.95
if you want to move in you can move in
but you gotta [ __ ] me
i need i need to be [ __ ] a lot man you
get rip free food free rent and
everything else man there's a deal man
is that from your show no i'm just
fascinated by that guy
that's about as free as it gets i mean
he just doesn't care if his mother sees
that
or i mean you know
he knows where he knows what he wants is
that a bow in his hair
i think that's the background
dude gave out free rent though like you
get free rent
you get free food you the reason why
he's alone is he
he suffocates you yeah yeah yeah he's
very needy
very i need to be [ __ ] and to be
[ __ ] alive he's like okay and
it sounds like you know if you were into
that that he would be enjoyable for
about two three days
oh it would tire you out yeah men from
jail
homeless or um you're a thug want to
come
move in a friend can move too man free
rent you get at least in a key
[ __ ] piss on me beat me i'm home you
know you see me when i come over today
and try it out try it out man
try it out what do you think no i'm just
trying to think what happened he
definitely was not built up as a child
no all that stuff beat me pee on me and
all that it's just like your parents are
just
i think this whole childhood we're just
yelling you're not good enough
yeah it's probably disappointing you i
wish the kid across the street was my
son and not you
that's horrible [ __ ] like that i felt
bad for that guy i know however
same time it's funny however yeah but
you know what's funny is like he so
hates himself that he just [ __ ] he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
um i mean how do you get like this no
how does he have a job like what do you
mean
rent free like what are you doing
like does he drive like a ups truck and
like they're gonna see that and be like
well you know
he what he does in his own time he's not
uh
but we can't give him any
black-and-white partners though that'd
be true yeah
just deliver in the white neighborhood
so
we keep that side of uh um what do you
think about drug use what do you think's
going on yeah i think he's a little high
yeah those those rings around the eyes
are pretty serious i think
but that's such a crazy mustache that if
he shaved that off i don't think i'd
recognize him
it isn't i didn't even really think
about the mustache it's a good point
very cheap yeah yeah it's like dated
it's very good
look and if he wants to attract men let
me try it out so you guys replied only
as [ __ ] man i'm looking for hardcore
guys i mean i want to do it i mean it i
want to deliver it i'm a hot
spot by trash come jump let's [ __ ]
it's a good offer rent free he's a hot
[ __ ] dumpster
yeah he's got a lot going on
doesn't he have enough pain in his life
he's got to be on this show too
you know that was that wasn't like
low hanging fruit that was actually
if you did that in a movie if that was
the character you would be nominated
because
that was an amazing performance i
actually uh
what i was kind of addicted to was his
cadence yeah the way he he had a very
unique way of seeing you
know i'm talking about where they're
like the the morbidly obese
uh runway modeling and you're like we're
beautiful and you're like
i don't think no i think if you're going
to be in a movie you should be if you're
going to get naked on film
and tv movie you should be in the best
[ __ ] shape you could possibly be yeah
or
you go the other way for the laugh but
you're doing it for the laugh
but like to to sit there and just show
off an
unworked out body and say that that's
brave right it's like
the bravery is the person who has to
look at it
yeah because listen we all look at each
other's [ __ ] regular bodies you know
when you're in a relationship yeah
because you love the other person right
you have to love
somebody right you know what i mean
that's what's amazing about beautiful
people
is you're not in love with them but you
can see them naked right
that's how that's that's that's really
in shape right
i mean i know the whole idea is like no
one wants people to see me naked you
know i joke you know what i look like
naked i look like i have the exact same
body as the pink panther
but it's just a big head and it's just
straight down no ass
and then i have like like the pink
panther it was like first trimester
yeah like and but there was but we live
in an age though that if i was
completely naked i would be called brave
yeah
courageous rather than [ __ ] rude yeah
and inconsiderate to make you guys look
at me oh yeah i mean i've been asked to
i mean be
uh shirtless i'm like it's disgusting
like is it for because it's funny
because if it's going to be funny that's
one thing but like
yeah like i would do it if if like it
can i act
like i think i'm good looking right
right then i would do it right
but if i'm going to do it like yeah
seriously this is my body deal with it
and and and literally put the pressure
on you to not
laugh at me and ridicule me is i am
living in such a world of [ __ ]
delugement i don't have any [ __ ]
pigment
yeah just for me no matter what shape i
got into to take my shirt off i would be
blinding people
right yeah yeah but i have i have other
things that i'm good at the weirdest
story anybody's ever said
on an extra that like made me
uncomfortable
from the beginning tim no it's the
serial killer like
tone of his his complete lack of emotion
thank you
can i tell you something this happened
yes yeah
you know what and i know bill i think
missing from that story was the sound of
somebody gagged screaming in the other
room
right now i know that you [ __ ] go
yeah and i know that you suspect that my
husband is a psycho i've heard i've
heard about he is
yeah no i know and i've i actually agree
yeah
and i've been trying to prove this on
this show it's just like you know
there's like bud in this bud light
there's like
psycho and psycho light like he just
he's not the uh the high calorie one
that can't get married and have kids
that's right
yes but if you if his thoughts were a
movie yep
yeah definitely nc 17. yep he's a
functioning
psychopath you know why because when i
started dating him bob this is a true
story when i started dating tom segura
back in 05 there were red flags little
stuff
like when we were remembering little
dead animals behind your
apartment but i remember you know in the
beginning you're all lovey-dovey
and uh and he'd be like i like you so
much
i like you so much i just want to gouge
your eyes out i want to squish your
face and kill you and and put a
sledgehammer in your head
like remember that stuff tom you're like
i love you so much i just want to smash
your
goddamn head in i'm being serious
somebody said that about my kid one time
oh my god look at those feet i just want
to cut them off
and i was just like yeah yeah [ __ ]
lunatics
yeah right there you can't you can't be
with a person like that so well
if you ever need a safe house we got a
guest room
well i'm two kids deep now i think i
used to say like i want to put your head
through that dress
yes yeah yeah but i was like as an
expression of love
right and there were other things too
like because you don't like love and you
hate that it makes you feel weak or
something that you want to violently
take it out on her that's exactly right
that's exactly right yeah and you know
it worked out
it did actually were you frustrated that
you knew you had no control over the
love that you had for your wife
so then then you just you were starting
to feel trapped i think it was more of
like
that i didn't know how to express how
good i felt you know so i thought
no no he really just tried he tried to
play like dim-witted there
yeah see i see that's from my fellow
calculated
yeah you're everything you need to be to
make in this business yeah
you just can't be creative and just be
floating around like oh that tickles my
artistic fantasy oh you know
what you're looking to write a
prescription i feel like this is the end
of a therapy session
i'm going to send you a quick okay just
let me see what is a quip
it's a toothpick it's a toothbrush is it
a good one yeah it's really good it's a
fancy one really fancy one
please tell me
is this how you handle your
relationships and people what i should
have bitched about something bigger
yeah [ __ ] ate my car you know
let me get you a car
now you've been with your lovely wife
for how long how long you guys been
together
uh i don't know like 14 15 years it's a
[ __ ] yeah it's a good run
i love it more than ever oh see she's
just [ __ ] happy
it's nice i know it's refreshing i hate
when people hate their spouses you can
always i [ __ ] about her on stage but i
i love her
i do no but you meant it i [ __ ] saw
that bit
and you meant it all right don't yell at
me so
you can put my head through the dresser
because i love you
you're always looking for ways to spice
it up every relationship is i would
wonder do that to me i'm wondering if
that's what you're looking to do don't
say that
you will consider something different
hi melanie and i'm scotty old with
ecstatic hearts
tantra and we just want to share that
there are many ways to orgasm you don't
actually have to be having sex
you can orgasm just from hugging
you know what's funny is they like if
you switch their hair they could be each
other
they look just like each other
you